as the u.s. death toll from the wolf flu
hits 100 some experts are wondering
whether grinding the global economy to a
halt might have been something of an
overreaction we examine the scientific
data and the philosophical reasons why
the left never lets a crisis go to waste
then President Trump officially secures
the Republican nomination for president
and Joe Biden is set to sail to his own
party's nomination if he can only
remember who and where he is all that
and more I'm Michel Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the crisis we are in a
crisis crisis I think there are so many
crises I don't know if I can even keep
all of them straight in my mind here are
some numbers to update you on the wolf
flu pandemic the u.s. death toll has now
reached 100 coincidentally that number
is the same number of people who will
die today in car accidents I'm not
advocating some particular policy over
another
I am simply giving you those two numbers
to give you some perspective you have
been watching the mainstream media
shriek and wail and gnash their teeth
and rip rip their garments and tell you
that this is the end of the world it's
been about two months since we had the
first confirmed case of wolf flu Kong
flu corona virus in the United States
100 people have died
an average 102 people will die today
from car accidents I'll give you another
number
7450 - that's the number of people who
will die today just cuz just cuz that's
how many people die every day in the
United States
7450 - now of course is it a very bad
thing if more people than that die
unnecessarily because of a pandemic yes
that's a very bad thing but why do I
mention 7450 - and then shin that number
because if the media talked about seven
thousand four hundred and fifty two
deaths today if they focused in on
everyone every story every 24 hours a
day you were hearing about this you
would think that something is terribly
terribly wrong and yet that's how life
goes just every single day nothing
really we can do to stop it here's
another number to give you perspective a
lot of people keep comparing the United
States to Italy because Italy had a bad
response to the corona virus they were
sort of uniquely situated to have that
virus run roughshod through the whole
country we're told that we're 11 days
behind Italy Italy had a confirmed case
eleven days before us and so if you look
at where Italy is that's where we're
gonna be in 11 days except that isn't
true so at this point we have a hundred
confirmed dead at this point
in Italy you know levin days ahead they
had 200 confirmed in so they had double
the number of deaths from coronavirus
and our population is five and a half
times larger
alright that's shows you something I got
yelled at on Twitter the other day
because I pointed out that Italy and
America are different countries people
were so upset by that because we all
have to be alarmists we all have to be
in the crisis all of the time there's
there's no limit to what we should do to
stop the crisis alarmists are saying we
need to look and listen to the experts
I'm a little skeptical of experts most
people should be skeptical of experts
experts tend to know a lot about their
one very narrow field and they don't
know a lot about
everything else there is one expert who
is urging caution you probably won't
hear about him very much in the
mainstream media his name is John ayan
v's he's a Stanford epidemiologist his
specialty is meta science meta science
is like the science of looking at all
those bogus scientific studies right
your science of science and he's a very
respected epidemiologist so he looked at
what's going on in the the data here
right and what they're seeing is
projecting the diamond princess
mortality rate so that was that cruise
ship on to the age structure of the u.s.
population the death rate among people
infected with kovat 19 coronavirus would
be 0.125 percent he goes on but since
this estimate is based on extremely thin
data there were just seven deaths among
the 700 infected passengers and crew the
real death rate could stretch from five
times lower 0.025 percent to five times
higher 0.62 5% adding these extra
sources of uncertainty reasonable
estimates for the case fatality ratio in
the general US population vary from 0.05
percent to 1 percent that could be the
death rate 0.05 percent to 1 percent
that huge range markedly affects how
severe the pandemic is and what should
be done a population wide case fatality
rate of 0.05 percent is lower than
seasonal influenza if that is the true
rate locking down the world with
potentially tremendous social and
financial consequences may be totally
irrational it's like an elephant being
attacked by a house cat frustrated in
trying to avoid the cat the elephant
accidentally jumps off a cliff and dies
that is from john i io needies i don't
know if i'm pronouncing his name
correctly but what he's saying is
absolutely sensible and you're not
allowed to inject reason and sense into
a crisis because the crisis has to be
all emotion all of the time but he makes
a very good point on the data we'll get
to that in one second first I gotta
thank our friends over at LifeLock
something tells me over the next couple
weeks you're gonna be
spending a lot more time indoors and
online because of coronavirus and what
that means is thieves will have more
opportunities to steal your identity
especially during tax season there's a
lot of uncertainty right now in tax
season is it going to be delayed the
filing deadline anyway I'm sure there's
going to be a lot that's going around
the internet with your valuable
information
criminals can steal that information
from your device's and sell it on the
dark web or use it to commit identity
theft to help prevent this you need
LifeLock LifeLock is the number one most
recognized brand in identity theft
protection
LifeLock monitors for uses your personal
info alerts you to possible suspicious
activity and if you become a victim of
identity theft a dedicated identity
restoration specialist will work to fix
it nobody can prevent all identity theft
or monitor all transactions but LifeLock
means one less thing to stress about
during tax season join now and save up
to 25% off your first year go to life
law comm / Noll scan in wles that's life
lock calm / Knolls for 25% off the point
that this epidemiologist from Stanford
is making is we just don't have reliable
data and so you see it among the people
freaking out on the internet you know on
the left right and center they're saying
look there we have this very small
sample size there's very limited
information and we're all gonna die if
we don't shut down the global economy I
don't think that there's sufficient
evidence to draw that conclusion and we
are making massively destructive
scission decisions based on those
limited data I'm not saying it's
necessarily the wrong decision that
we're making but it is certainly the
case that the decisions were making or
destructive think about how many people
are out of work right now think about
how much wealth has been completely
destroyed think about how many
businesses are gonna go under as a
result of this think about what the
world is gonna look like two or three
weeks from now once the crisis of the
wolf flu has passed maybe it was worth
it maybe it wasn't worth it maybe we
overreacted I'll give you an example of
a policy the
that may very well be worse than the
thing it's fighting right now I kid you
not in cities across America one of the
responses to the corona virus is to let
criminals out of prison that's true LA
County announced that it would let six
hundred criminals out of jail because
what you want during a time of crisis
uncertainty and panic is more criminals
on the street right that makes sense I'm
so glad we elect these guys they're so
smart
they totally get it right now in
Philadelphia the Philadelphia Police
Department will no longer be making
arrests for all narcotics offenses any
kind of narcotics offense you're selling
you're using you're buying whatever
you're good you're not getting arrested
a cop can watch you sell crack cocaine
on the street you will not be arrested
theft from persons a cop can look at you
watch you rob somebody and say well my
hands are tied I can't arrest you
anymore because of a Chinese virus
because of it limit let's see how this
logic makes sense because of a Chinese
virus if a police officer watches a
criminal rob an old lady on the street
he can't arrest the guy okay retail
theft you go and rob a store can't get
arrested for it enjoy the stores are
yours go go on in
robbers you'll you will get off
scot-free
theft from auto busting and steal the
guys radio that's that's totally fine
burglary break into somebody's house
vandalism bench warrants stolen autos
cool man grant it's gonna be Grand Theft
Auto all over our streets except in real
life now economic crimes such as passing
bad checks
we're gonna need bad checks because
nobody's gonna have any money pretty
soon fraud and prostitution that is all
now effectively legal in Philadelphia as
a response to a very bad flu does that
make sense to you does that make any
sense at all the argument the reason
as they say is because they don't want
to overcrowd the jails so I guess then
there's a chance the prisoners get the
woo flu even though the infection rate
certainly the mortality rate for people
who are under sixty and seventy very
very low they don't do that when there's
a particularly bad seasonal flu do they
they did they do that during swine flu
which killed 15,000 Americans or more I
don't think so
so they do it during the Ebola crisis
they said okay no more we're not gonna
arrest people now for crimes I don't
think so
alarmists always tell us that an
overreaction is better than an under
reaction they say this is true all in
all cases all the time we have to
overreact is that true let's say for
instance just just using the crimes that
are now effectively legal in
Philadelphia as an example let's say as
a result of this all these policies one
person one extra person survives the
virus but then another person overdoses
on heroin because you're no longer
making arrests for narcotics offenses
person overdoses on crack gets hooked on
some horrible drug ruins their life or
flat-out dies then was the policy worth
it I don't know even if you're making
this kind of cold utilitarian
calculation of just the sheer number of
people who are gonna live or who are
gonna die you haven't saved a life in
that in that hypothetical right let's
use another example let's say that as a
result of this policy one person
survives the virus goes on to live
another three or four years mostly
healthy but a girl falls into
prostitution because you're no longer
making arrests for prostitution so it's
easier for pimps to prey on them and the
number goes up ruins your life was that
worth it
I'm not saying it is or it isn't I'm not
even at this moment advocating one
policy or another though I certainly
have thoughts on some policy
like this dumb jailbreak decision in
Philadelphia in Los Angeles and other
places too I'm I'm simply asking are we
sure that an over reaction is always a
good idea you let all the criminals out
of prison what could go wrong there
maybe it would have been better not to
do that
maybe it would have been better not to
close down every single business maybe I
don't know I'm racing uncomfortable
questions it seems very clear though to
me that an overreaction is not always
better than an under reaction Orange
County right now I saw a new regulation
going around the internet I believe it's
legitimate I heard it from a pretty
legitimate source that you can be
punished with fines or jail time if you
were caught walking outside in certain
places in Orange County California with
people who are not in your household so
I'm I'm in my apartment you know get
sweet little ELISA there we want to go
on a walk that's okay if I want to meet
a friend who doesn't live with me for a
walk I could go to jail does that make a
lot of sense doesn't make sense to me is
that legal
I'm skeptical crisis always serves the
left this is something that even
well-meaning conservatives have
forgotten during this coronavirus thing
conservatives need to keep a cool head
here because otherwise the left will
transform our society transform our
politics before we even know what
happened the left thrives on panic and
crisis that is why they are always
trying to gin them up okay a great
example the last crisis before this
crisis is the environmental crisis
that's what they call it right initially
was global cooling and then it was
global warming than it was climate
change now it has become climate crisis
which is really really the sweet spot
for the left and the climate crisis says
kind of sends a little bit similar to
what we're hearing now that the whole
world is gonna end in 12 years or ten
years or eight years or six months if we
don't take dramatic action that
radically transforms our
society that just coincidentally and
conveniently gives the left everything
they wanted for a hundred years if we
don't pass the green New Deal and payout
reparations for slavery then the Sun
Monster is going to kill us it's a
crisis the environments gonna fall apart
what do reparations for slavery have to
do with the environment no idea no time
to ask questions how dare you ask a
question we're in a crisis just pass it
we got to read we got to pass the bill
so we can find out what's in the bill
it's what they told us during Obamacare
- crisis crisis does not serve
conservative ends ever we'll get to why
in a second first I got to thank our
friends over at ring speaking of our
safety and security listen while you're
being holed up at home during the
coronavirus you are gonna want to know
who is at your door before you go and
answer it especially if things get a
little rocky I mean I don't think that
people sitting idle for weeks at a time
with whole cities shut down they're not
always the most well behaved people all
right so you're gonna want to have a
little bit of protection ring gives you
protection at every corner it helps you
create custom affordable security for
your home rings video doorbells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime doesn't matter where you
are you can be in your bedroom lying
sick from wool flow you can be in the
office you can be at a beach rings full
home security systems give you
everything you need to protect your
family pets and property get a special
offer on the ring welcome kit right now
when you go to ring.com slash knowles KO
wles i had dinner last night with
friends that I gave ring to they love it
they talk about it all the time you are
going to want if is well that a welcome
kit includes the ring video doorbell
two-inch I'm Pro it's all you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home ring comm / Noll scanner wles
it's a ring calm and / Knolls always a
crisis about the water crisis remember
there's a water crisis and so we need
massive government intrusion into our
lives you don't hear about that one as
much anymore that was more popular maybe
five five or ten years ago hopefully the
crisis got better what about the
overpopulation crisis remember that one
that's a real deep cut that one comes
back from the 70s they were still
talking about it though in the 80s
the nineties that there are too many
people so that's why you've got to go
along with the left's agenda on sex
abortion and everything you have to done
government interference and those things
you have to do it because we've got an
overpopulation crisis you remember in
the 70s they talked about the Population
Bomb that if we didn't have all these
radical leftist policies really inhuman
policies especially in terms of abortion
if we didn't have that then within 10 or
20 years there'd be mass starvation all
over the world what happened the world
population doubled and were richer and
fatter than ever before looks like we
survived that crisis I'm real glad we
didn't listen to all the alarmists
during that crisis where there's one now
on college campuses you're this all the
time the campus rape crisis we are told
that one in four or one in five women on
college campuses are raped they will be
raped that number that's a shocking
terrifying statistic right then you got
to think about it for a second if that
statistic is true then Harvard Yard is a
more dangerous place for young women
then downtown Aleppo you can saunter
around the outskirts of Baghdad late at
night you'd be much safer than if you
walk through old campus at Yale does
anybody really believe that no of course
not
but it's a crisis don't don't ask these
questions we need to deprive people of
their due process rights that's that's
one response to the the crisis on campus
they have instead of instead of putting
rape which is very serious crime through
the criminal justice system which is set
up to deal with serious crimes they have
campus tribunals with professors the
acting as judges and jury and
executioner and at least figuratively I
don't know maybe literally two they set
that up well you and if you took two
moments to think about the crisis the
statistic you say wait a second you're
telling me we need to get rid of our due
process rights in America the rights of
the accused run roughshod over those
people's rights because you're saying
that Harvard Yard is more dangerous than
than Karachi I don't is that true I
don't think they'll they have to
push you past the point of reason in
order to get you to buy into their
radical conclusions crisis always serves
the left because crisis means that
everything is broken it's not just like
a little inconvenience it's not just a
little problem
little problem is actually a good place
for conservatives because conservatives
are in the business of conserving we
like to fix things fix things up a
little bit but not totally destroy them
or totally change them we want to
preserve we want to conserve the
tradition now obviously over time things
wear down they need repair they can be
improved but that that's where a
conservative thrives if you're in a
crisis everything is broken you've got
to start from scratch you got a
fundamentally transform America to quote
Barack Obama this is very advantageous
to the left this is intrinsically not
conservative it means there's nothing
really worth preserving things have gone
so horribly wrong so what's going on in
this crisis what are people saying when
you get past the tweets when you get
past the mainstream media what are
people really saying about this well
people are saying that President Trump
is doing a good job you don't need to
just listen to the Republicans don't
need to just listen to the conservatives
even some of the most left-wing
Democratic governors in America who are
working with Trump on this crisis on
this pandemic spray the more precise
word to use or saying that he's doing a
very good job it's pretty shocking
if all you watch is CNN but if you're
looking at people who have actually
interacted with this administration you
realize there's actually been some
responsibility accountability efficiency
Governor Andrew Cuomo of New York came
out and he said you know the Trump
administration doing a great job this
government cannot meet this crisis
without the resources and capacity of
the federal government I spoke to the
president this morning again he is ready
willing and able to help the speaking
with members
his staff late last night early this
morning we need their help especially on
the hospital capacity issue I think the
president was 100% sincere in saying
that he wanted to work together in
partnership his team has been on it I
know a team when they're on it I know a
team when they're not on it his team is
on it they've been responsive late at
night early in the morning and they've
thus far been doing everything that they
can do and I want to say thank you and I
want to say that I appreciate it
thank you I appreciate it man that's the
different tune than we've been hearing
from some Democratic officials for the
last three years who say that Trump is
Hitler and he's terrible and he's a
Russian who stooge and we got to throw
him out of office and he's a racist and
a bigot net well the people who were
working with him even high-ranking
Democratic governors of very left-wing
states are saying he's actually doing an
excellent job here it's not just and
equal moe because you might say well
Andy Cuomo he's probably known Trump for
a while they're both New Yorkers known
each other a long time no it's not just
and equal Moe Gavin Newsom Democratic
governor of California said almost
exactly the same thing we had a private
conversation but he said we're going to
do the right thing and you have my
support all of our support logistic we
had otherwise so before he made those
statements publicly I had a private
conversation with him around 4:30 West
Coast time and he said everything that I
could have hoped for and we had a very
long conversation and every single thing
he said they followed through on so I'm
I'm just not interested in and finding
daylight on those statements because
every single thing his administration
and it starts at the top including the
vice president has been consistent with
the expectation that we repatriate these
passengers and we do it in a way that
does justice to the spirit that defines
the best of our country and the state of
California sounds pretty good they've
they've been very supportive they
followed up on all of their promises
looks like the Trump administration is
a good job I think now we talked about
yesterday how the left is trying to just
use this crisis in a very just basically
political partisan hack way to attack
Donald Trump all the time
when you hear that I don't think you
need to send them those people the
updates from the coronavirus task force
I don't think you need to send them even
the statistics send them those clips
send them to maybe the two most
prominent Democratic governors in
America saying that the Trump
administration is doing a good job which
I think up until this point certainly
they have been doing an excellent job
now there were some proposals on the
table that are maybe not as excellent as
what we've seen here to four from the
Trump administration we'll get to those
in a second we'll get to some of the
polling on what Americans think about it
and we will get to the 2020 race but
first I've got to thank our friends over
at first leaf oh man this is gonna be
the most important thing well you are
quarantine in yourself you need first
leaf wine I love first leaf i they gave
me a freebie first leaf and I loved it
so much now I pay any anything I'll give
them my credit card I say to whatever it
is send me more of your product first
leaf created an introductory six pack of
wine for me based off of a quiz that I
took all for just twenty nine ninety
five six-pack of wine for 2995 these
wines normally go for at least twenty
bucks apiece and you can get them for
five bucks apiece for your introductory
box when the bottles arrive this is
what's so cool you try them and they
were really excellent wines but you know
one or two I'm like yeah that's not my
taste so I rate them down the next box
is includes wines I didn't even know I
would like but it's totally tailored to
your taste sign up today and get six
bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping just go
to try first leaf comm slash Noll
scanner wles trust to the company that I
use to help me relax at the end of the
day that six bottles of wine for only
twenty nine ninety five plus free
shipping at try first leaf calm slash
Knowles all right there's a lot that the
Trump administration could do it's on
the table right now there's
even a chance that we might all be on
the yang gang now there's a proposal for
a sort of proto universal basic income
free money from the government what
could go wrong we'll get to all of that
first I have got to say goodbye to
Facebook in YouTube I head on over right
now to daily wire.com slash subscribe
very important we actually just launched
a new show it's called all-access live
over at daily wire.com it's been daily
wire god-king Jeremy boring they kicked
it off Monday evening Jeremy and I did
one last night so you can go check that
out we're gonna be doing episodes for
the rest of this week at 8 p.m. Eastern
5 p.m. Pacific
I really like it it's pretty much just
hanging out the thing I like most about
it it's a perfect example of the market
working for us you know it at any other
time in history we probably would not
have had the technology that we do now
that we're able to just go straight back
into your homes as you are sitting on
your couches and and just speak to you
during this time of crisis when we're
all quarantined that's all access live
go check it out it's initially for our
all access members but that's that's
what we want to do ultimately but right
now it's for all you guys so head on
over daily wire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
all right so what do Americans think
about this response last month 77% of
Americans expressed confidence in the
government's handling of the virus that
was before all the quarantine estarán
sand bars were closed before everybody
was thrown out of work because of
overzealous mayors and governors and
those sorts of people 77% expressed
confidence in the government's handling
of the virus that number has dropped
substantially the current level is 61
percent of Americans who say that they
are very or somewhat confident in the
government's response 24 percent say
they're very confident 37 percent say
that they're somewhat confident the drop
is entirely Democrats and it's by the
way we should look at the wording of
this question how confident are you in
the government's response that includes
the federal government Trump but also
the state local government if for me in
Los Angeles Eric Garcetti is the mayor
Gavin Newsom is the is the governor so
if I were asked that question I would
say well I'm not confident in the local
governments response I am confident in
the federal government's response but
that's not really included in the
question so the drop is entirely
Democrats less than half of Democrats
express confidence in the government's
ability to handle an outbreak
Republicans remain as confident so with
the polling reflects is that what we're
seeing right now is a leftist freak out
not only in terms of policy but even in
the reaction to the policy conservatives
feel basically the same way that we felt
a month ago most people think the Trump
administration is doing a good job here
Democratic governors of the two most
prominent left-wing states think that
the Trump administration is doing a good
job here all things seem to be under
control
so why the freakout the answer here is
the media
you remember Mara gay Margay is the New
York Times editorial board member who
was on MSNBC the other day with Brian
Williams and she confused her arithmetic
by six
orders of magnitude when talking about
Mike Bloomberg you remember that
somebody tweeted recently that actually
with the money he spent he could have
given every American a million dollar
got it let's put it up a screen it when
I read it tonight on social media it
kind of all became clear
Bloomberg spent 500 million on ads u.s.
population 327 million don't tell us if
you're ahead of us on the math he could
have given each American 1 million
dollars and I've had lunch money left
over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's true it's disturbing oh it's true
it's disturbing it's amazing it's wait a
second it's just not right it's wrong by
six orders of magnitude okay that Maura
Gaye who then didn't apologize for
saying that she actually then wrote a
column about how if you criticize her
for getting her math extraordinaire a
wrong and then you're a racist that's a
member of the New York Times editorial
board didn't take any responsibility
anyway she's back and she is
exemplifying the media dishonesty in
this crisis against President Trump so
Maura Gay tweets this about President
Trump quote Trump told governor's this
morning they are on their own
respirators ventilators all of the
equipment tried getting it yourselves
mr. Trump told the governor's during the
conference call a recording of which was
shared with the New York Times that
sounds pretty bad doesn't it he's saying
you're on your own wow what an
irresponsible feckless fewer federal
government they can't even get the
equipment they're saying you're on your
own we can't do anything right except
that's not what happened the very next
line which Mara gay left out quote we
will be backing you but try getting it
yourselves point-of-sales much better
much more direct if you can get it
yourself that completely changes what
the first sentence means and Mara gay
knows this the New York Times know this
so they take out the part that shows
what the government response actually is
and they take the first line twist its
meaning completely and make it seem like
Trump is pushing all of the
responsibility onto the stats states
when when Trump is telling them
respirators ventilators try getting it
for yourselves that if you say try
getting it for yourselves because we're
not going to get it for you that means
something very different then try
getting it for yourselves we'll back you
but it'll be more direct and simple and
quick if you get it yourselves
those are completely different meanings
mara GAE in it would seem intentionally
twisted that I don't know how it
couldn't have been intentional the New
York Times had the recording presumably
Margay read the article so she just
tweeted something out that was false
that was a lie it was a lie Trump did
say those words but the words meant
something completely different when you
leave out the crucial part of the
statement that's what we're hearing from
the media that's why I'm saying if
you're looking at the media right now
and you're panicking and you're freaking
out just don't it's dumb so don't tune
it out these Pete you're gonna listen to
Mara Gaye she's gonna tell you the truth
I don't think so you know if you want to
whip yourself up into hysterics then go
watch The Lying mainstream media but if
you don't if you want a more realistic
view of what's going on then
you gotta look elsewhere so what's the
Trump administration's new response now
things are getting a little bit dicey
Steve minuchin Treasury secretary gave a
press conference yesterday in which he
talked about a new policy for relief
that the federal government is
considering this came to them from Mitt
Romney so just to give you a little
preview of of how great great this is
gonna be wonderful conservative
reasonable came from Mitt Romney the
policy is to send direct checks to
everybody free money here is Steve
minuchin announcing the policy although
the president likes the idea that the
payroll tax holiday I will tell you what
we've heard for many people and the
president has said we can consider this
the payroll tax holiday we get people
money over the next six to eight months
we're looking at sending checks to
Americans immediately and what we've
heard from hardworking Americans many
companies have now shut down whether
it's bars or restaurants Americans need
cash now and the president wants to get
cash now and I mean now in the next two
weeks I will be previewing that with the
Republicans there's some numbers out
there they may be a little bit bigger
than what's in the front maybe even
bigger than what's in the prison what's
in the press is a thousand dollars so it
might be bigger what 1,500 2,000 2,500
who knows one man in particular in this
country is particularly excited by all
this what did you say about Mitt Romney
that he's joined the yang gang members
certainly under the worst circumstances
anyone can imagine he's joined the yang
yang we're all in the yang gang now man
the one of the most radical Democratic
candidates for president looks like his
proposal is being endorsed by Mitt
Romney that's no surprise
Mitt Romney is one of the most radical
Democratic candidates for president wait
hold on he was a Republican sort of
maybe but it is disappointing to see the
Trump administration talk about this I
guess we're all on the yang gang but
it's a bad idea
why is it a bad idea well let's give the
policy it's due if the policy were
simply the government giving people
short term direct relief one time
without any other consequences whatever
that's fine is it gonna work I'm not
convinced it would work but I don't have
any major problem with that it would
probably be better if it were on the
state and local level rather than at the
federal level because people are just
more responsive there it'd be it'd be
better if we could figure out exactly
who the money should go to because look
we've all taken a hit during this
coronavirus but some people don't need
the money
some people really do need the money
some people can afford to miss two weeks
of work some people can't afford to miss
two days of work so you want the money
to be targeted to the people who need it
because there is real relief that has to
come from this awful virus that came out
of China we should send China the
invoice
no question about that but if it were
just in a vacuum
I could almost understand it if the only
stimulus they were considering was
giving people this direct money I could
maybe understand that that's not the
only stimulus they're considering
they're considering a whole lot more as
well you've got every major a lobbying
group now going descending on Capitol
Hill to try to get some of that money
it's a bad idea
because it will set a precedent this is
the precedent for the universal basic
income the yang is thrilled about it the
supporters of the universal basic income
are thrilled about it and the universal
basic income is awful it's a terrible
idea there's no argument for it it's
inhuman it's a way to ensnare you and
get you trapped and dependent on the
federal government not even a more local
government which is at least easier to
shake yourself out of at least there you
can move at least there these are
laboratories of democracy each of our
state governments but this would be a
federal program do we really think
you're gonna mail somebody thousand
dollars two thousand dollar zero three
thousand dollars there's one time
checked for relief we really think it's
gonna be one time what if the
coronavirus goes into July they're only
gonna go one check three thousand
dollars even is not going to last you
through July what if it goes away and
then you this because viruses die in the
heat and then the summer is fine and
then it comes back again in the fall
we're gonna get another one thousand two
thousand three thousand dollar check we
can another trillion-dollar bailout
program we'll need one we do look we
need one the economy is collapsing
because of these dumb policies some
policies are smart some policy is pretty
dumb trouble with the crisis is you
can't really sift the smart ones from
the dumb ones is this gonna be the last
bailout I don't think so is this gonna
be the last we've heard of ubi I don't
think so it's going to be the precedent
and it's going to go forward and become
a regular policy we might not get yang
style ubi now but we will get a lot
closer to it we will hasten that day of
getting ubi style redistribution if
a republican conservative administration
does this got to be much much more
careful about this and the states are
really happy that the federal government
has been supporting them maybe we need
to support the states and if you want
direct relief and by the way people need
direct relief ok people you can't just
go in and say hey nobody can work for
for two months alright you're on your
own right you can't do that
that's wrong too you need some way to
make them hold but a massive bloated
inevitably corrupt program from the
federal government that's gonna set the
stage for a massive new welfare program
probably not the way to do it
alright the Chinese government is not
making this any easier on us in this
crisis Chinese government is now I can't
tell if they're parroting American
leftist propaganda or if the American
leftists are parroting Chinese
propaganda it's a real chicken or egg
situation but China is jumping on the
identity politics bandwagon they are now
saying that it is racist to refer to
this virus as a Chinese virus to call it
the Wuhan virus or the wolf flu or the
gun flu or the Chop fluey or the
sweet-and-sour sicken or lung pao
chicken or there are a lot of obviously
there are a lot of nicknames for this
but China doesn't have a problem with
any of those names in particular China
has a problem generally with pointing
out that the virus came from China
the new service China Xinhua News which
is a mouthpiece for the Chinese
Communist Party they tweeted out quote
racism is not the right tool to cover
your own incompetence racism if you call
it the Chinese virus the Wuhan virus if
you point out where it came from
you're a racist China is obviously
stoking divisions that are already in
the United States worth remembering for
our useful idiot friends who who parrot
propaganda from communist governments
the these totalitarian regimes have been
doing this for a long time so during the
especially during the 1960's the Soviet
Union was handing the Fanning the flames
of racial division because the America
experts in the Soviet Union know a whole
lot about our political divisions same
thing in
China the Chinese Communist government
does a lot about our political divisions
they are fanning the flame and useful
idiots in the United States are
parroting that propaganda don't parrot
that if you call the wolf flu or the
Wuhan virus or any of those terms if you
call that racist
you are parroting the propaganda of one
of the most evil regimes on the face of
the earth
doctor foul Qi doctor foul he gives us
another update foul Qi is the he's the
kind of public face of public health
here in the corona virus epidemic he was
asked is this president Trump's fault is
the lack of testing president Trump's
fault he says absolutely not he says
that's no nobody's fault but certainly
not the president's fault
so when you hear left wingers blaming
Trump saying but the testing or there
aren't any tests you've point them to
dr. pouchy all right dr. pouchy has a
lot of credibility who's been around in
public health for decades and decades
and he said yes it's too bad that we
don't have a lot of testing but it's not
the president's fault it's part of the
system before we go I got to get to a
little bit of 20/20 News last night
President Trump officially clinched the
Republican nomination for president poor
bill weld his primary challenger is he's
done he's finished obviously Trump was
going to get it though
there is something worth noting here
turnout has been very very high there
the Trump campaign actually posted a
video about how high the turnout has
been Cruz's to victory with a
record-breaking Republican turnout Trump
got more total votes than Obama got as
an incumbent well we can turnout
operation in Texas is extraordinary a
pleat domination receiving more primary
votes and than any sitting president
we have record turnout for an incumbent
president the Republican Party has never
been unified like it is
turnout was also huge for Donald Trump
celebrating a record-breaking victory
the party for the person Obama had by a
wide margin
[Applause]
how good Donald Trump's political
operation is to all Americans tonight
I'm with you the Americans
[Applause]
and we are going to keep America great
keep America great there it is I mean
this is a big number we've been talking
about it since New Hampshire the
Democrats are expecting record high
turnout in 2020 and yet the turnouts
been lower than it was in 2016
very often in states all around the
country whereas President Trump who is
guaranteed to get the nomination
his turnout has been doubled that of
Barack Obama when he was looking at
reelection of George W Bush when he was
looking at reelection it's been double
that so what does that tell us it tells
us there is still a lot of enthusiasm
for Trump and if the numbers hold on the
government's response to coronavirus
then looks like those those turnout
numbers will hold in November unless the
economy completely tanks and that's a
real open question right now on the
other side of the aisle Joe Biden just
clinched the Democratic nomination for
president he clobbered burr I mean he
didn't clinch it but he clinched it
right he didn't he's still got to go and
get all the all of the delegates but he
a clinched it he won Florida Arizona and
Illinois he now has 1147 delegates to
Bernie's 861 Bernie does not have a path
to victory right now the only reason
Bernie is staying in this race is in
case Jo collapses I don't mean that
electorally I mean that physically Joe
Biden does not seem to be particularly
vigorous we there was he was giving a
campaign speech the other night and at
the end of it he just stood there like
he didn't know where to go he didn't
know what should happen next and his
wife actually had to come out and try to
drag him off the stage thank you all
thank you all for listening
oh thanks thanks thanks okay
yeah
so what is that I mean we don't we don't
know what it is maybe they were filming
commercial maybe he was giving a small
speech we don't it's been floating
around the internet outside of context
but whatever he's doing there
I hope he's not in front of a large grad
it's totally quiet but even if he's just
standing there in front of a camera
giving a message he looks like his
zombie he looks like he's gonna give us
thank you thank you all for listening
and then he's sort of standing there
oddly and and his wife kind of walks out
looking nervous and we're just like ah
okay Joe and then gives him a hug oh hey
you're there huh okay okay all right
well that's not a candidate who looks
like he's about to run away with the
presidency and so Bernie's staying in
the race to try to take it from him it's
gonna be a much more exciting election
now than we thought it would be when the
economy was going gangbusters I thought
Trump win fifty seven states now another
crisis or maybe the reaction to the
crisis is throwing that reelection
victory into great question I guess
we'll have to wait and see how the rest
of it shakes out and hope the President
Trump doesn't overreact to the
overreaction which would put us in even
more peril all right that's our show
come back tomorrow and I mean to have my
Michael Noel's this is the Michael Nolt
show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]